Now, let me show you the remaining code.
before we talk about
the softmax or sigmoid
activation function
So if I scroll down here?
I am going to go.
review the
model by typing model
dot summary the summary method is going to
create a table that
Indicates our architecture and the
number of parameters of this model has learned.
So if I run this now?
Give it a few seconds for the data set to be downloaded.
And why is it complex?
missing parenthesis
So here you can see your the
architecture of your neuron at work.
And assess here that you can learn this model can
learn a total of 122,
000 parameters
which relative to other pre-trained models this is very
insignificant like the resident 50 model I
think has
six digit or seven digit
so it's it's billions of parameters.
The more you parameters a model to learn.
the well
the more
capabilities the more our variation can handle
so we've built a model, but we haven't traded yet.
so the train that we're going to use the
compile method
So that the model knows.
Which algorithm to use to back propagate
the weights again, if you watch the video that I
put on Slack?
This ID should be familiar to you.
But the idea is to keep on.
Feeding this neural network these pictures again and
again and again.
and each time
it is fed through the network the updated
wage. Remember we the point here is to adjust the weights.
And we get the model to predict.
images
with labels that are closest to the original label so we
want
The difference to be eliminated we want
to reduce error to zero.
And empirically we'll do this with cross entropy,
which we'll talk about in a moment.
I'm going to go model. Excuse me model that compile.
the optimizer
is Adam Adam stands for Adam is actually
an acronym.
adaptive moment estimation
Moment.
in statistics is a
is one of the details that describes the shape of the data.
So one moment is for example.
Variance, that's the spread of
the data.
Another moment is the mean.
The center the central tendency of the data.
Another one is the skewness.
So if it has a long right tail or
a left tail and kurtosis is the peakness.
This word is borrowed from physics, but it has a slightly different
meaning in physics. But an estimation
is well.
It's prediction.
But the naming a neighbor side this is
going to be used to find the or adjust
the weights. Then we have the last function.
which is
TF dot Keras
Dot
Sports
categorical
cross
entropy now cross entropy is a loss function.
That can be used.
for binary classification
But in this case since we have every picture you can
fall into either one of 10 classes we want.
Well, we have multi-class classification. So we
will use the sparse variant of it again. We'll look
at the moment of this in a second.
And then we go from logics.
You'll see what a logit is in a second from Logics equals
true.
and metrics
for a classification the
we have a couple of metrics.
There is accuracy precision and recall.
If this time will I'll talk about Precision recall.
But basically we want this number to convert to
one.
So we want accuracy to be 100%
and what we want the laws cross entropy.
To convert to 0. So again, you're looking at two things the loss function. This
has to be 0
the closet is either the better.
And the met the accuracy.
The closer to one the better.
Let me put these on separate lines.